hey guys it's max today we're doing a
full comparison of the pixel 5 against
the samsung
s20 fe i've been using both of these
and there are a surprising amount of
similarities but some pretty big
shocking differences that i found
that i haven't heard a lot of tech
reviewers talk about so today we're
going to be covering everything from the
displays the quality
battery life charging times cpu
performance
and even things like 5g speeds let's
start out with the exteriors
and one thing that's very weird is that
the s20
fe actually feels more premium than the
pixel
even though this back is completely
plastic whereas with the pixel we have
aluminum
that is covered with resin it feels kind
of like pressed cardboard or cardstock
and because the size of the s20 you have
exposed aluminum
and has a little bit more weight overall
it feels more premium now on the back
you guys could definitely see that
there's a size difference that's because
the pixel 5 has a six inch display
compared to a six and a half inch we're
gonna do a detailed display comparison
in just a bit now you also will notice
that the pixel has this fingerprint
reader on the back
it is pretty comfortable you pick it up
it's a small size phone
you can log right in compared to the s20
fe which has an optical
underneath the display sensor now i will
say i've been using this over the
weekend
it does not work as well as the
flagships that use ultrasonic sensors
and overall i like pixel's
implementation a little bit better
even though it's not as futuristic and
high-end you'll also notice that there's
a difference in the camera bumps
the pixels is almost flush so that's
nice if you don't like your phone
rocking on the table
the s28 fees isn't bad but it is bigger
and you'll notice that we have three
cameras on the back we'll save the
camera test
for a little bit later in this video the
fe does have a larger battery than the
pixel
but i would say the pixel actually is
pretty good compared to the previous
ones 4080
compared to 4500 now the battery life is
actually
very similar almost identical for a few
reasons
now included in the box are a few
chargers
the pixel actually comes with an 18 watt
charger
and that will charge up in about an hour
and a half the samsung even though has a
larger battery and a smaller charger 15
watt it actually charges about an hour
and a half
as well very interesting but if for the
samsung
if you buy a 25 watt charger you can
charge it up in one hour
both of them have wireless charging and
reverse wireless charging which is great
and water resistance is actually
identical on
both now moving to the front both of
these
use cutouts instead of a notch which is
great
and we don't have a huge forehead the
pixel 5
has really even bezels all around so it
looks nice but they are a little bit
bigger
than the fes on the sides the fe is a
little bit uneven
but both look good now if we compare the
cutouts here it's interesting how
um the pixel has a really big one
you guys can see even though the sensor
isn't as big
whereas the samsung has a much smaller
cutout now you probably can't see
a speaker grille on either one of these
that is because
one the pixel 5 doesn't have one it
actually vibrates the display
to make sound for your earpiece speaker
and for stereo sound during video
now the s20 fe just like their flagship
samsung's it actually has a hidden
speaker grill
it cuts out part of the screen here so
you don't really even
notice it but it's there with that said
now let's go ahead and compare the sound
quality head to head
so you guys can hear the difference for
yourselves put on a good pair of
headphones
and let's take a listen
[Music]
[Music]
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below i'll give you guys
my opinion because i'm hearing
it firsthand not through a microphone
and through youtube
and i have to say that i don't think
there's ever been a bigger difference
in a smartphone speaker comparison that
we've done the pixel 5
the bottom firing speaker is putting out
most of the sound and even then it
doesn't sound
great the the top firing or actually the
display vibrating
it has no bass very little mids and the
volume level is very
low so the sound does not sound stereo
at all
and it's a shame that even the pixel 4 8
which is 350
sounds better and louder than the pixel
5
whereas the s20 fe has one of the best
speakers i've ever heard
second place behind the note 20 ultra
matching up
with the s20 ultra it is loud it sounds
great
and if you listen to music or watch
movies on your phone
you definitely want the fe now let's
compare the displays where we have a
shocking amount of similarities
and just a few differences now the most
obvious difference is the size
we have six inches compared to six and a
half inches the resolutions are almost
identical they're both 1080p
panels the pixel 5 has a little bit
extra pixel
density because of smaller screen but
the sharpness and detail
looks almost identical i cannot tell the
difference now one thing that surprises
me about the fe
is that this 1080p panel actually looks
better
at 1080p than the note 20 is because
that is a higher screen but then if you
drop it to
1080p for that 120 hertz smoothness it
actually looks a little bit worse than
this one so don't be concerned about the
fe
being a 1080p panel it looks really good
now the other difference
is the refresh rates we have 90 hertz
for the pixel
compared to 120 for the fe
now i was surprised by how little of a
difference i could tell
with my eyes occasionally i will get
some stuttering with the pixel
but it's actually because the processor
not because of the screen refresh rate
now
here's some slow motion footage 4k 120
hertz
of both of them scrolling side by side
see if you guys can tell a difference
and let me know down in the comment
section but in the real world 90 hertz
looks just fine
comparing the brightness if you set it
to manual the pixel does allow itself to
get a little bit brighter
but if you're in auto brightness mode
surprisingly they're both
very similar and as far as reflectivity
and off axis viewing they're basically
identical too
one interesting difference we found is
that the pixel 5's hdr video looks quite
a bit better
because for some reason samsung is
limiting the brightness for hdr video
and now let's talk about performance and
this is where things get very
interesting now i'm excited to test out
and compare the five
g speeds which we're going to do in just
a second but first we're going to
compare the cpu
speeds and then we're going to touch on
graphics so both these have snapdragon
processors
the s20 fe has almost a top-line chip we
have the 865
compared to a 765 g
in the pixel 5. now the pixel 5 does
have two extra gigs of ram we have eight
compared to six let's go ahead and do
our cpu test
and we'll see how they actually compare
and here we have the scores
and the fe is more than 50 faster
in terms of single core and pretty much
double in terms of multi-core
performance the difference is
massive and yes you guys already know
that the pixel 5
it actually gets outperformed by not
only the pixel 4
even the pixel 3 outperforms the pixel 5
because
google did choose to go with a much
slower processor
so yes there's a big difference now i do
want to mention that as far as your
normal usage
when you're going through your pages
you're scrolling through websites your
typical simple stuff
you can't really tell a difference in
fact i much prefer the pixels
stock android i like everything the
layouts
the keyboards uh everything without the
extra skin on there
but if you're gonna be keeping these
phones for multiple years
and both of these are saying that
they're gonna get three years of
software support
the samsung is still gonna be fast three
years from now where with the pixel
i still every once in a while get little
glitches and uh
longer load times for app stuff like
that three years from now it's gonna be
a very slow
device now before we compare the
graphics performance
i want to go ahead and test out the 5g
speeds because we also have a difference
let's go ahead and run the test we are
here in spokane
in a business kind of area with a lot of
people here
and inside a concrete building so let's
see how the pixel 5
does so we're looking about 33
32 download and our upload speed
is looking right around 20. and now
let's test the s25g
we're manually connecting to the same
exact server and it looks like our
speeds are
very close here almost identical and as
you guys see
our speeds are fairly slow here
in in spokane in general now i did test
out
these in other parts and i also tested
the note 20 and one very interesting
difference between these two is that the
pixel 5 even though it does support
millimeter wave 5g it only has 2 by 2
antennas and the modem is the
x52 modem which is actually half the
speed of the modem that is inside
of the s20 fe so if you're in an
area where you have faster speeds
overall
for example the note 20 which has the
same modem i was able to get
about 160 in spokane which the fastest i
ever got on the pixel here
was in the 50s range and now let's go
ahead and compare the
graphics i have 3d mark opened up right
here
and let's go ahead and run them this is
a newer test
you guys can see for yourselves the
difference in
this gaming test the fe looks smooth
running at about 25 frames per second
but the pixel is super
choppy it also started to test about
five six seconds longer
to load it and we're getting at about
six frames per second here
and for the scores the fe scored
almost four times faster pretty much
right there
so if you're a gamer yes you can play
the latest titles right now
on the pixel you're gonna have to turn
down the graphical settings but think
one two or maybe three years down the
line and
you're not gonna have a really great
experience where the fe
is perfect right now and it's still
gonna be powerful a couple years from
now
and now let's talk about cameras and
this was always
pixel's strong suit so we're gonna see
how these two
compare now i do wanna let you guys know
that we're gonna have a camera
comparison an
unbiased blind one which are always so
much fun
if you guys haven't seen those yet
between this pixel the fe and the
upcoming iphone 12 that we're gonna get
later this week so make sure you guys
subscribe enables notifications so the
pixel has a 12 megapixel front-facing
camera
and on the fe we have a 32 megapixel a
much bigger sensor
so here is a shot with both of them you
guys let me know which one
i look better in this year the pixel
ditched the telephoto for an ultra wide
so both of these
do have ultra wides but the pixels isn't
as wide as you guys can see right
here and google said that's because they
want to have less distortion if you guys
see these images the samsung definitely
has
a lot of distortion there on the ceiling
but the weird thing is
if we actually take the photos you guys
can see them side by side right now
the samsung actually fixes the
distortion
for you in software so i don't know if
that's a good excuse for google
and then if we zoom into the edges
samsung's has
less noise and more detail than the
pixel's ultra wide
as i mentioned the pixel doesn't have a
zoom lens anymore where the fe
offers a three times optical zoom and if
we match up the maximum that the pixel
can digitally zoom which is seven times
you guys let me know which one looks
better of course google is known for
their software so here's a night mode
shot
it's very interesting the difference in
white balance
and here's a night mode shot using the
telephoto cameras or the zoom feature
and here's a portrait shot the pixel
does force you out of 1.5 times crap
where the samsung won't let you crop
until afterwards and you can get wider
portrait shots
let us know which images look best down
in the comments section below but do
keep in mind we're going to have an
actual
detailed comparison that's unbiased and
there's going to be a bunch of different
shots there so you guys don't want to
miss out make sure you enable those
notifications
all right guys let's finish off with
storage prices and then
the final verdict as far as storage both
have 128 gigabytes which is the sweet
spot for 2020
going into 2021. the samsung it does
have a micro sd
card slot which is great because for
very little money
you can buy a card you can pop it in and
get extra space
you can also pull it out put it into a
camera or a laptop so the fe
is more versatile as far as prices here
in the states both of these are
seven hundred dollars but if you're
outside the states there's some areas
where the pixel is a hundred dollars
less because it doesn't have support for
a millimeter wave
out there which the fe doesn't actually
support
either i wish actually google left out
that support and made this phone 100
less expensive i think it would be
excellent price for it
because even if you're in a city one of
the few ones that do have millimeter
wave
the speed won't actually be maximized
because this
has a much slower 5g chip
with half the antenna bands compared to
the fe and other samsungs and onepluses
so
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
now with at this price point
comparing everything the processors the
displays
comparing the speakers everything else
both these phones have to offer
i think the samsung offers a lot more
for the money
we still have to do more testing on the
cameras which we're going to see
but it's hard for me to recommend the
pixel for 700. where the samsung gives
you
a lot more hardware and a more premium
feel with a high refresh rate screen
and way better cpu and graphics
performance but you guys go ahead and
let me know
down in the comment section below which
one do you think is a better value and
which one would you buy
thank you guys for watching click that
circle above to subscribe and if you
guys want to see a couple other great
videos we have them right over there
this been max and we'll see you in the
next video